dice un panadero usa ocho tazas de
harina para hacer una hornada de
bolillos completa la tabla para la razón
dada y aquí en la tabla tenemos la
cantidad de jornadas de bolillos y de
tazas de harina puedes ver que cuando
tenemos una jornada necesitamos ocho
tazas de harina entonces cuando tenemos
dos jornadas cuántas tazas de harina se
necesitarán y cuando tenemos tres
jornadas cuántas tazas de harina se
necesitarán pausa el vídeo e inténtalo
bueno si tenemos el doble de ordenadas
entonces necesitaremos el doble de tazas
de harina y el doble de 8 es 16
entonces 16 tazas de harina y si tenemos
3 veces el número de jornadas entonces
necesitaremos el triple de tazas de
harina el triple de 8 es 24 24 tazas de
harina después nos dicen
atrás a los padres ordenados x james de
la tabla en la siguiente gráfica es
decir tenemos que graficar una hornada 8
tazas dos jornadas 16 tazas 3 jornadas
24 tazas así que vamos a hacerlo en el
eje x tenemos jornadas y en el eje y
tenemos tazas de harina es justo lo que
nos dicen acá arriba por lo tanto una
hornada ocho tazas se va a ver como un
punto así para una jornada necesitamos
ocho tazas justo aquí 5 6 7 8
para dos jornadas necesitamos 16 tazas
de harina así que para dos jornadas
voy a poner 16 tazas de harina y para 3
jornadas
necesitamos 24 tazas de harina así que
voy a poner 3 jornadas y 24 tazas de
harina
podemos ver que como nuestra razón de
tazas de harina jornadas es constante
todos estos puntos están en una misma
recta debido a que tenemos una razón
fija observa cada vez que nos movemos
uno a la derecha
vamos a subir ocho unidades
cada vez que me muevo uno a la derecha
subo ocho unidades es decir cada vez que
necesitemos otra hornada vamos a
requerir ocho tazas de harina extras
bien hagamos otro ejemplo
danielle gana dinero lavando autos de
sus vecinos los fines de semana
daniel cobra una tasa fija por cada auto
que lava dos puntos en el siguiente
plano coordenada muestran cuánto cobra
daniel por todos cinco y ocho autos y
aquí lo podemos ver cuando el abad dos
autos ganan 15 pesos cuando el lava
cinco autos gana 37.5 pesos y cuando el
lava ocho autos gana 60 pesos
una forma de pensarlo es que la razón
entre el número de carros que lava y el
dinero que reciben es 2 a 15 por cada
dos autos cobran 15 pesos cuando la base
8 automóviles estarías multiplicando por
cuatro la razón entre autos y pesos por
lo tanto el dinero lo multiplicaremos
por 4 4 por 15 es 60
una vez más tenemos
una razón fija y por lo tanto estos tres
puntos están en la misma recta y después
nos preguntan cuánto cobra daniele por
cuatro autos bueno si por dos autos le
pagan 15 pesos por el doble de autos por
cuatro autos es el doble de 2 le pagaran
el doble de dinero es decir 15 por 2 lo
cual es 30 tenemos la misma razón y ya
puedo decir que el cobrará 30 pesos muy
bien hagamos otro ejemplo más ahora
tengo este marcela gana dinero cada vez
que palear la nieve de sus vecinos
marcela gráfica puntos en un plano
ordenado para mostrar cuánto gana por
diversos números de veces que ella pelea
nieve
y bueno aquí lo podemos ver cuando ella
palear nieve tres veces gana la mitad
entre 16 y 20 18 pesos cuando ella
palear nieve cuatro veces ella gana 24
pesos y 5 veces ella gana 30 pesos
parece que la razón es constante y es de
3 a 18 es decir ella gana 18 pesos por
cada tres veces que palear nieve o dicho
otra manera por cada vez que ella palear
nieve ella gana 6 pesos así que veamos
que nos preguntan
cuál de los siguientes pares ordenados
puede agregar marcel a la gráfica escoge
una respuesta y me dan tres puntos
la primera opción me dice que cada vez
que ella palear nieve obtiene 10 pesos
lo cual es falso es inconsistente con
los datos que me dieron si ello obtiene
18 pesos por cada vez que palear tres
veces nieve entonces por una vez que
palear nieve obtiene seis pesos no diez
pesos y por lo tanto no es la opción a
la opción ven me dice que por cada vez
que ella palear dos veces nieve ganan 12
pesos y eso es cierto si la razón de
palear a pesos es de 3 a 18 o de 1 a 6
será equivalente a 2 y 12 así que
seleccionaremos esta opción
vamos a comprobar y lo hemos logrado
hasta el siguiente vídeo